all right let's talk about this guy so
Augustine is a Christian philosopher
we're now moving into the era Buffett
this time it's called the age of faith
we're leaving the ancient period and
entering the naval period life seems
kind of a cusp guide for that he
actually saw the fall of Rome it's not a
very nice thing to happen but that's
kind of you know the end of an era isn't
it
Cicero Aristotle Plato all those guys
are part of ancient Greek and Roman
philosophy
Augustine is one of the fathers of early
Christian philosophy were there other
Christian philosophers and Jewish
philosophers before him yeah definitely
there's a lot of people that are called
the church fathers there were these
Hellenistic Jewish philosophers like
feel of Alexandria but Augustine is the
guy that we're going to focus on and
part two is very important in the
development of Western flock now let's
talk first about this guy's method
there's a few things that should have
jumped out at you or that you should
have done remarkably let's think first
please a Christian right how does that
play out for him a lot of times in
somebody's a Christian when it comes to
you know these deep murky philosophical
matters how do they solve them for
themselves
yeah so what does that what does that
look like in if we translate that down
to like the base level and how they
interacted I've got the religious views
I don't know maybe they how they need
certain things sure those that's the
content so like you know when somebody
talks about God then they've got
something to say or morality or you know
creation versus evolution or things like
that how do you actually know what their
views are how do they express it yeah
yeah a lot of Christians will work by
what we call proof texting they'll cite
a Bible verse there's that's all the
issue right
think about discipline because any of
you ever heard spare the rod and spoil
the child
yap now maybe you'll use it with your
kids right because what it means is you
should beat your kids otherwise your
kids are going to turn out bad and it's
a Bible verse right I think it might be
in Proverbs or one of the other wisdom
literature and actually I think most of
the people could use this don't know
don't know where the Bible it actually
is they just know it's in the by ecwid a
lot of things that people say area in
the Bible that aren't in the Bible we
got actually read through it kind of
carefully
you know like god helps those who help
some help themselves not in the Bible
right then people attributed sometimes
now is that satisfying when somebody
when you've got a real problem you're
perplexed about something and somebody
says yeah he really know it's in the
book look page then and the Bible said
page we said chapter and verse right
look at chapter verse that can be
satisfying sometimes is that really
satisfying you've got a deep nine
problem like let's think about some of
the things that are going to trouble you
in the next 10-15 years somebody you
know is going to die somebody that you
care most likely within
10 to 15 years probably for a lot of you
from big families people already have
you've already asked the question where
did it go when he happens to them
Scott care about them it's got not care
about them these are things that bother
people right especially especially kids
experience death as a kid somebody opens
up the Bible and points to verse is that
going to make you feel much better why
not
this is just words okay it's just words
yeah they're good words you may not be
related yourself there's a problem - you
may not be religious yourself yeah some
things when the context in the Bible
don't make much sense yeah there's
there's some interesting passages where
you gotta really work to figure out what
they're talking about I think you some
of the other recipes yeah
I think another reason why these things
are not why it's simply proof texting is
not satisfying this because as human
beings we have a desire to know the
other desire to understand that's part
of our rationality that makes us
different than the other animals
Augustine is really keyed into them you
notice that there are some mentions of
Scripture in the dialogue who does most
of the mentions of the scriptures of
Augustine or is that is the 10th tend to
be his student that's the be his student
well obviously was doing something a
little bit different yeah and this is
often when we talk about Christian
philosophy
there's this verse in there that long
scene actually sites from Isaiah unless
you believe you will not understand
this is coming Isaiah I don't know
chapter verse I'm not checkers first guy
good enough for me to know what book it
comes from and chapter and verse are
actually you know a new innovation that
came about when we started printing now
what's going down here when he cites
this does he cite this to shut his
student up and to say we're done talking
about this issue or is this a starting
point okay this is a starting point
what's a starting point for let's think
about you know when he actually ends up
saying this it's fairly early on
Augustine says being kind of
autobiographical here he says you're
inquiring into a problem which deeply
interested me when I was quite a young
man troubled me so much I was worn out
and driven right into heresy
boxing's are really interesting guy in
his biography his confessions solo did I
fall if such as the mass of empty fables
which overwhelmed me that have God not
helped me because I longed to find the
truth so notice what's going on he's
talking about himself is longing to find
the truth right when we ask these deep
philosophical questions we're in the
same condition as obviously we're
longing to find the truth we don't just
want some cat the answer we don't just
want our minds to be still
we want our minds to rest in something
that we can
rely on that makes some sense to us
that's that's you know what we do not
just in philosophy but we do it in all
of our other disciplines as well so he
says I couldn't have escaped or
recovered the primary freedom of search
as I made great efforts to solve this
problem I'll explain it to you on the
wall on the way I finally worked it out
very low by the way God will help us and
make us understand what we believe we
can be sure that we're treading and the
path pointed out by the Prophet it says
unless you believe you will not
understand so notice what he's doing
he's not saying well the prophets of
this or their forward we're done with
thinking about it he says we can use
this as a mob this shows us the way to
to approach things doesn't actually
solve any problems for us it shows us
that we're on the right track and it's
quickly going to be reversed for honesty
you know if you're going to see first
you have to believe and then you'll
understand but what is Augustine really
interested in is he's really interested
in somebody believing or as he
interrupted this he's interested in
understanding and once you actually have
some beliefs that's nice you know if
you've got the right beliefs you're on
the right track
sort of like remember with play-doh with
right opinion and knowledge that's right
opinion if you've actually got the right
movies that's knowledge that's being
able to give a rational account the
Christian philosopher doesn't just want
to believe they want to be able to give
reasons for what it is that they believe
and then if they find out that the stuff
that they believe doesn't actually make
sense there's got to be something wrong
with the way
they made sense of those passages or
beliefs they have to work at it there's
there's an effort given him to work of
human rationality you don't turn your
mind off if you're doing the kind of
philosophy that Augustine for this day
you don't just quote you don't put the
Bible and be done with the things
quoting the Bible sometimes just makes
things even more murky because you know
everything that gets bloated and you say
well I believe this do you understand it
yet you have to be able to explain well
what does this actually mean how does
this when you talk about some Bible
verses don't necessarily make sense with
other Bible verses that's a problem
yeah the Christian philosopher wants to
make sense out of that and that's part
of what Augustine is do is notice he
doesn't begin this whole things starting
with a scripture phone saying what is
this this verse that would be doing
theology instead what does he begin with
it begins with a question you know is
God responsible for evil and we're going
to come back to that in just a second
there's another thing that I must point
out about his method he's got this this
guy that he's working with a student
right the phoniest and over and over
again you see this is common pattern
taking place though this one for a
problem and that there's a solution
that's sort of building blocks of
right it's God responsible for evil no
it turns out God is not responsible for
evil but then that raises other problems
doesn't it wait a second if you're
saying this then aren't you also
committed to this but that doesn't make
sense either well then you gotta find a
solution to that and that right in stop
and so on
raise further problems right this is not
something where you reach a point the
dialog except at the very end of these
three books where they say oh okay now
it all fits together it's a process and
it's a process with a lot of stopping
points notice that if odious one of the
other issues that we talked about what
makes actions that are down there right
you got that from the reading right what
makes an action too good or bad
boria suggests all sorts of solutions to
it and obviously don't say yeah okay put
them what about this now there's a new
problem and they're honing in on ffense
you guys do things like this in other
venues when you don't quite know the so
you know you don't quite even fully
understand the problem that you're
working with the more that you work at
it the more clear it gets and you know I
came up with part of the solution and
you know okay this part at least has to
be fairly reliable but now let's let's
see if we can find the part over here
that fits into it or you know think
about here's a different
for you how many of you guys have done
puzzles puzzles what's the first thing
you do reporter well you know you're
right you find the corner pieces first
all right
and then borders and then what how do
you do things after that problem there
there's other things besides just trying
pieces out of your Hanham you'll never
solve thousand piece jigsaw puzzle yeah
you like you know you actually look at
the box too sometimes well there's
supposed to be a bear there so this
brown stuff must be the bear bears head
this lighter brown must be his Bell here
you know none of the balloons that he's
holding appears a red wine Audrina you
start looking for patterns you start
looking for you know connections and
gradually you can actually build the
whole thing out did you have something
else in there yeah yeah I wonder if
there's other ways in which people do
this
maybe there's a professional jigsaw
puzzle solvers who have some other
technique I don't know all I know about
is with this Augustin is going to be
using concepts the same quick and we're
probing deeper and deeper and deeper and
what are we here's where another thing
to think about what are we probing
deeper and deeper and deeper in fib
really two things what is the human
being and are we doing this what would
faculty ever uses in particular sounds
not our sensitive right we got how are
we different from the animals
rationality rationality which is part of
the human being
to make sense of the human being and who
else is in the picture god these
dialogues are also going to be about
John and we are using our rationality to
try to understand about God and God's
relationship to human being things start
to get very kinda complex the circular
don't this Augustine and people who
follow August would say that what he's
doing is he's delving into realities
that are hard for us to understand
they're murky they're complex there
wasn't easy enough for God but we're not
God we're human beings and what we're
doing is we're delving into something
that ultimately rests on mystery but
which can't be made intelligible through
our use of rationality through our
collaboration in part with God because
where do we get rationality from in this
this sort of the framework you're going
to give it to us yeah and it's not like
you know with the scaffold part of the
skeptic response to this rationality of
yours is you know ken about the poison
gift isn't it Augustine says yeah that
you can go wrong in a lot of ways but
it's not your rationality that's going
wrong it's other things so that's that's
a good segue into now thinking about how
he's going to get got off the hook you
could think of this dialogue as in large
part getting God off the hook for
various things that might be reasons to
complain about the guy because you know
God did give us reason didn't he
and he gave us all these capacities and
do we human beings do do bad things do
we do a lot of bad things we have whole
history books full of bad things we have
done to each other is that something
from just from the past you know it's
all history so we're still doing bad
things to each other
we even like to make movies
people doing bad things to each other
and to themselves you know we come up
with like we imagine new ways to do bad
things to each other there's a lot of
bad stuff going on any whether you call
it bad or evil or wrong obviously we're
going around the character it's it's bad
now here's one of the issues now that
comes up throughout the back what do we
say about God in you know the three
major monotheistic religious traditions
you know Judaism Christianity Islam what
are they all have in common so it's not
going to the Trinity what but also they
haven't come literally how exactly God
is everywhere as you know whole big
discussion what else that you seem to
fall from all-powerful right doesn't
knowing the power now remember where
we're going
evil these don't actually constitute a
problem for their being evil right I
mean you could have a guy who like knows
everything and can do anything but says
I could care less stupid human beings
whatever nonsense that they engage in
man it's good to be a guy glad I'm not
one of them yeah we're gonna say he's
supposed to be like the definition of
good at the same time personally
involved
yeah explicitly you know the person
involved is very important too that
could be like part of that omnipresent
so I'm totally isn't it I suppose
integrity guide right that's what he is
entirely good not just a little bit good
not just like good to limits and saying
yeah you know I'm gonna like I'm gonna
help you guys out and I might pick you
up 50 times but the 50 first time that
you screw up you're on your own Jack you
know that's not what it means to be
entirely good this is a problem right
because if you had a deity like this who
has all of these sort of attributes but
we know that there's an evil in the
world doesn't there seem to be a
contradiction there wouldn't God made
the world you know much better if he if
he really is all-powerful you know you
could say well you didn't make didn't
design it wrong well that's not gonna
get an infinite god-awful I guess it
presumably
yeah so hardest thing was going to have
that as as the ultimate answer mr. yeah
now here's that's the crux that's the
real thing that Augustine is worried
about beryllium is God responsible for
the evil and he created everything right
so he created goodness didn't he also
create evil and say and you can say what
you don't read that nah that's people
they screw things up but that we're
putting the same problem that the Stoics
had earlier on before Augustine came on
the scene because people could say to
them
didn't your God know that when he was
creating people they'd screw it up that
that's also something that longus needs
did you say so hold on to that thought
Keith says that evil is aprende ssin of
the good or corruption yeah
one thing I find rather conflicting just
with the sense of God and Christianity
he's at the very beginning of the
creation stories yeah it with the whole
like beginning of
yeah there's the scene where he is
talking to God and God is inquiring like
how do you know this holiday you and he
acts like he did not know anything that
just happens yeah well you know
Augustine doesn't think that the origin
of stories are to be taken literally
some parts of them are supposed to be
taken someone's talents are and here's
what we can say sort of like from
scriptural scholars point of view these
are these are stories that got sort of
mashed together from a couple different
sources like there's actually two
different creation stories one of them
is supposed to be the full copic
tradition and the other one's supposed
to be the sapristi tradition and they
get involved with the other into this
book that we call Genesis which just
means a book of oranges yeah you know
there's other puzzles that come up to it
like you know who did can marry you know
and so if if the viewpoint is this book
is supposed to be sort of the blueprint
for every single thing that took place
it's supposed to be exhaustive the truth
of the origins then you get that some
real problems logical problems either if
you understand it as being sort of
something that be overlaid over
presumably whatever else is going on
that didn't get recorded you know like
for instance we don't know Holly out of
us that didn't presume oh it wasn't
really that relevant and whoever wrote
about Cain you know getting getting
married and father and children
presumably knew that there are other
people somewhere Donald
and Augustine's not worried at least at
this point about those four puzzles
he's worried more about something that
actually faces us even if we took a
veneer out of the picture the question
is where this came from this would still
be a problem for us how does how do we
get evil and one one option is to say
well it's those human beings they
they're the ones who make the trouble
but then you got to explain you got to
do a bit more explanation about well you
know God created human beings why don't
you make them better one sex and you
also have to explain how do humans be
able to do the wrong thing and that's
what we're going to focus on the most of
it yeah well a sensation right okay
you're actually I'm to something that
again Augustine is going to talk about
because we're we're going to go wrong
ultimately has something to do with
their animal nature and it actually does
have something to do with evil as
privation so let's see let's sort of
walk ourselves through its conversation
with of odious and I'm gonna have to
leave out a few issues that come up
along the way I'd like to the
distinction between eternal and temporal
thank you very much they can say finite
but it was right temporal law and this
stuff about is okay to kill people
sometimes let's just sort of plow along
through the Bo Deus is possible so
this is something that's probably
bothers everyone yeah at one point maybe
about other people maybe about yourself
why do people do and closely connected
with this is another question actions
yeah what is it in these bad actions
that actually some bad enough odious
proposes you know some sort of external
consideration is at first and you know
if you think about this when you were a
little kid how did you know that
something was wrong before they don't
like your conscience started telling you
that it was wrong some people do it was
bad yeah and how did they tell you
yeah generally they didn't say now
listen you know Timmy or the reality
whoever I just wanted to talk with you
cuz I seemed doing something and I I
notice that it's really not the right
thing for you to do that's not the way
parents talk is it sometimes they
actually like talk with a good you know
smack we've tried to avoid that these
days but an ancient culture so it's
pretty common
they yell a right you know that you're
doing the wrong thing cuz they say knock
it off you know
thanks to it on camera that's an
external authority telling you that
something is wrong
so are you suing says let's let's start
by thinking about some things that are
actually wrong we need some examples to
wrap our heads around if he brings up
adultery murder and sacrilege and murder
we can all relate to that that's
something we're pretty sure is wrong
right
sacrilege he has to do with desecrating
holy things maybe some of us would have
a harder time relating to that but if
there's something that you consider
fully you probably can understand the
ancient sort of yeah it was something
terrible to do adultery on you know in
the society that we live in currently
I would say that the prohibitions about
that become very weak but we do still we
do still tend to think that if you are
in a committed relationship the engine
cheat on the person whether you're
married or just you know dating or
living together or something like that
that's a bad thing right
once you've actually committed to
somebody if you cheat on them that's a
bad thing and then also if somebody else
is in the committed relationship and you
try to seduce them out of that
relationship that's a bad thing so we
all agree on that yeah now Augustine
says let's work with them why what is he
actually wrong about the dollars and of
odious you know tries a couple different
tasks he says
one's illegal some locks
yeah ok I mean there's something to that
that's sort of like you know the kid
being yelled at by the parents saying
knock it off of them then punching no no
dessert for you you know go sit in the
corner timeout you know whatever it was
that they they did to punish it we have
this this stool that we had to spit out
when we weren't getting him and the
hitting was sometimes preferable to this
we have a stool he we had to sit on
facing the wall for 15 minutes and if
you asked how much time it passed the 15
minutes started together so you might
sit there for a couple hours you know
that you know that burned things into
your head don't do this thing that
doesn't really tell you why it's wrong
that's the fact that somebody passed a
lot of on something doesn't tell you
that's wrong so if you always try
something else he says you know look
what else would we use the golden rule
you know if you don't want other people
to do that sort of thing to you if you
don't like what other people treat you
that way then you shouldn't treat you
down that way that's gonna work for a
lot of things right you wouldn't like if
I came in here and knocked your books
off your desk so none of you should come
and knock my stuff off my desk the wrong
thing for us to do right well what if I
was into knocking things off desks so
much yeah I said hey I'll let you an act
with my stuff off because I'm gonna sock
your stuff off but it would it be okay
for me to do that that'd be what have
you actually said yeah I'm into that too
that's you know that's my thing we can
all do the same thing together but
there's still be something wrong with
that you might say the less wrong yeah
well here's maybe where our
sensibilities might differ well
obviously it actually uses this to talk
about swingers people who like swap
spouses this has been going on
throughout all history by the way
st. Anselm actually had to write a
letter to the
environment saying you got to knock that
off you know you claim to be a Christian
country but you guys swap spouses like
people swapping horses that's not that's
not what you're supposed to be doing
Augustine says you know somebody who you
know says you can sleep with my spouse
so long as I get to sleep with your
spouse they are still committing
adultery they are still doing something
in his view wrong so if it's not just
that you don't like what somebody's
doing it's not just like there's gotta
be some deeper reason that makes things
wrong so the votives comes back to you
know the law as they actually condemn
some people for than action that doesn't
help either so let's think again about
cheating and sexual cheat all right
maybe it's not some external authority
or some general principle
maybe the moral quality has to do with
the person themselves the state that
they're in why do people cheat fall out
of love because that's not enough to
actually get you getting bad with
somebody else
yeah they will they want to have sex
they have a desire they have what oxen
is calling - here's another possible
passion meaning this is the desire
that's actually wrong and cheating and
Augustine extras says hey even if you
don't manage to bring it off if you want
to cheat that's bad - you know that's
that's sort of like cheating in your
head we also talked about the difference
a sexual affair an emotional affair I
guess that would be along the lines of
what he's describing what does he mean
like by passion
so passion means desire and desire is
for some good thing fear is also related
to this and he says you know it's fear
the same thing is passion
not exactly but what's going on when you
actually have fear about something when
you're afraid you're afraid about losing
some good thing you're afraid about
soccer about not being able to hold on
to something they're not succeeding
right and really fear has to do with
designer and one of our primary desires
is to live without fear
all those feeds into to passion now what
are the sort of things that we we do
desire Augustine is going to divide
these into let me over here for a sec
Augustine is going to divide these into
several different categories and then
it's not one of the lines that we might
think of there are things we can do
against our wills one of those kind of
goods our lives you have somebody can
take away our life freedom freedom hell
right you get sick don't fall to your
home you know some people like it on our
runners super great shape when they drop
dead at 30 art attacks you know it's a
bummer for them but you know these are
those kind of goods relationships
prestige positions money yeah pretty
much any any material thing somebody are
there any things things anything you yes
and particularly it's on your life yeah
yeah and that's something that he's
going to lead us towards we we have of
the Faculty of will that is so powerful
that once it's in the right State
nothing can take that away except for
the drill itself and you might say well
why does anybody make a bad decision
we'll get to that are there any other
things that would be in that
things that can't be taken away from
your thoughts I suppose yeah in a
certain respect although we did
brainwash you maybe yeah yeah are you
seeing this kind of I think we would
probably say that some of our thought
knowledge could be taking away your
right to Augustine tends to think of
things like having these things sort of
indelibly on it until it gets rid of
them
yeah ah now that's actually getting very
close to what we're talking about trends
well dignity when we talk about dignity
what do we mean we mean some sort of
uprightness and self-esteem being able
to take some joy or see some goodness
and not just yourself by looking at your
body or even necessarily the knowledge
that you possess but in what you've
chosen in the kind of person that you
are now we can love a desire either one
of these things and Augustine early on
is going to say well when we go wrong
it's because we're loving these things
we're not loving the things that are
more permanent is that info I mean is it
is it really bad automatically to desire
money or desire friends yeah
to exchange anything else we maintain
those desires yes that's the key thing
for Augustine all of this has to do with
how we ordered it's not just what we
love but when we get down to the level
of what how do we arrange them what do
we put at the top will be put at the
bottom when we're actually living our
lives Papa what sacrifices do we make
how do our priorities play out I mean
think about here's what just a prosaic
example somebody says they want a
college education you've seen some
people drop out or not go to college
probably from their high school they
want a college education but they don't
actually go to college why not
what are they love more what did they
desire yeah whatever job that used to do
instead by the way work they say good
job yeah yeah some people like not to
work so much that they said yeah I'd
really like to have a college degree
but I value this other thing more for
Augustine the reason why we do wrong
things why people do wrong things he has
to do with the order of our laws the
order of our desires and if you stick
with the things that can be taken away
from us we're good to go
is that all of our lives I mean even the
monks have to worry about what they're
and eat you know or how to keep order in
the monastery who should be in charge
they get a big fights about that
actually do you study the history of
monasticism it's getting interesting too
because some of the church fathers
fantastic fathers let's say stuff like
man it doesn't do any good for you to
like go off and be a monk in the desert
if you bring yourself and all your
problems and your pride and your you
know tendency to dominate other people
with you even if you're totally on your
own we're still not going to be happy
you got to work on that stuff that's a
matter of figuring out how to rightly
board
and power rightly we'll with our faculty
these things that we that can be taken
away was like life like freedom like
friendships relationships like material
goods well Mike occasions of pleasure
the person who has a good will isn't so
attached to these things that they let
them draw them into doing the wrong
thing let's think about the adulterer or
just a sectional cheater what is the
good that ends up being sacrificed when
somebody cheats yeah I think I think
that's the primary good the relationship
with the other person
why Augustine would also say chastity
within the person themselves you know
which is a good disposition which can't
be taken away from you by somebody else
unless you let them do it now why do
people cheat there's actually more it's
not always just a sexual desire right
yeah so that I'm gonna get you back yeah
something's not being provided to that a
lot of swings lacking in their meanings
its relationship yeah
sometimes people cheat and it's not the
sex that they really wanted it's
affection it's being desired themselves
it's all sorts of other things that that
go you know these are the these are the
components of midlife crises right what
you guys will think about more later
down the line now what's going on there
the person is making a choice between
two different values the relationship
the relationship is it good the
relationship ends up being made into
lower good for that person then whatever
else is that they're the designer and
notice these are all things that can be
taken away if you have a relationship
with somebody they can take that
just by choosing they could be taken
away from you because they died if you
know if cheating is a genuine
possibility somebody else could seduce
them but it's a greater good the
relationship itself is a greater good
than satisfaction sexual desire being
able to get revenge these other things
and somebody who has a right will
chooses to put this higher than this see
the thing is we have the capacity to
choose with all these different Goods
and all the good things that we know on
experiencing our lives
we human beings have the capacity to
rearrange their order when you when you
have said to yourself man I'm screwed up
I need to get on the right track you
know you did you actually said now I
recognize this good is actually higher
than this good and I haven't been
favoring this one I've actually been
screwing it up let's fix this order
gently it doesn't work the other way
around you don't have a moment of
realization where you saying me and I
want to be damned let's rearrange these
things instead they kind of creep up up
and we didn't get through all the book
one so I'm going to pick up with that
next next class we'll talk about the bad
role of the good